i'm going to recommend you take one
teaspoon of this very certain spice
to help you greatly with diabetes now
when i say the word fixed diabetes what
i'm really going to talk about is how to
fix the complications
of diabetes i've done a ton of videos on
this related to diet and intermittent
fasting but today i'm going to talk
about just
some incredible benefits from this one
one spice cinnamon and the type of
cinnamon i'm going to recommend is
called cylon cinnamon so the natural
chemical in cinnamon that is doing the
heavy lifting is called cinnamaldehyde
and so it has some fascinating
research which i will put down below
that i just kind of got sucked into for
hours and just some like just blown away
you know cinnamon is the most consumed
spice in the world and actually it's the
oldest spice that was consumed from
quite a few different cultures
so what does it do well it's an
anti-inflammatory it's anti-microbial
it can kill microbes as well as candida
overgrowth in other parts of their body
it also has anti-cancer properties but
the big benefit that i want to talk
about is the anti-diabetic
effects it has potent anti-diabetic
effects okay
so the first thing you can do is
increase insulin sensitivity and the
second thing it can increase glucose
sensitivity
so just these two alone will explain all
these other factors because when we're
talking about
the complications of diabetes there's
really four main areas of the body we
have the kidneys we have the eyes
we also have the heart primarily the
blood vessel
and then we have the nervous system
your nerves on the bottom of your feet
and your fingers
start to lose circulation and they start
dying number three
decrease the risk of getting
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease if
you're going to lower glucose and lower
insulin you're going to suppress the fat
on your liver so you're going to have
less fat in your liver that's a cool
benefit
number four it actually has protective
benefits in the kidney so if your blood
sugar is high and you're taking cinnamon
it can protect the kidney from all the
problems that occur i mean think about
the the number one cause of kidney
failure
um that's diabetes so
if you could take something to reduce
the side effects to counter all this
these free radical damage because think
about what diabetes is you have this
higher sugar going through the body
think about sugar as being like rust
it's oxidizing it's rusting out the
different parts of your body now what is
a kidney kidney is a filter of your
blood so it gets hammered so this is why
a diabetic usually ends up with kidney
problems but if you can take something
to minimize the symptoms i mean that's
going to be amazing to increase the
longevity of your kidney number five i
found studies to show that it can
restore peripheral neuropathy
that is that nerve problem that i
mentioned before the bottom of your feet
you get burning tingling and painful
feet and there is a good remedy that i
like to use called benfotamine and alpha
lipoic acid but
cinnamon is another one you could use so
again what diabetes is doing to the
nerve it's
killing the circulation the blood
vessels the capillaries to the nervous
system so the nerves need a blood supply
so that's what diabetes is doing it's
killing off the blood supply and the
oxygen to the nerve and so the nerves
die and you start getting
you know all sorts of symptoms so
cinnamon can actually help
prevent that i mean think about what
happens when you have
higher sugar going through your your
vascular system
you're creating all sorts of
inflammatory processes you're allowing
cholesterol to go into the artery you're
creating damage and then the band-aid
comes in there with calcium and
plaquing and then you get a also
clotting so guess what cinnamon can
actually prevent or protect endothelial
cells number seven it can decrease the
risk of cataracts okay diabetes is the
number one cause of blindness but with
diabetes you also get cataracts glaucoma
and there's a whole list of eye problems
that can occur
all right number eight because you're
lowering glucose and lowering insulin
you're going to have
less
lipid accumulation and number nine less
inflammation in your brain why because
cinnamon is a
anti-inflammatory now how do you take
the cinnamon well
you can put it in your tea you could
take cinnamon tea you can put in your
coffee
you can take it as a pill form okay
that's a lot of people just take it as a
supplement you can also put in different
foods like there's a recipe a cinnamon
roll fat bomb okay and i will put a link
down below which uses kind of cream
cheese and whole whipping cream and
butter with cinnamon it's a great little
dessert
of course we also have
cinnamon buns right you can use that or
cinnamon toast and i'm being very
sarcastic because we're not recommending
that but anyway i wanted to increase the
awareness on just an amazing spice
to use
for
not just diabetes but if you also have
insulin resistance okay which a lot of
people have
the next best video for you to watch is
my one that i did long ago on diabetes i
think if you haven't seen that you
should check it out i'll put it up right
here